good afternoon everybody before we start
talking about viruses I want to remind
you one of the parts of the grade of
this course in addition to the exams is
there's going to be a quiz online weekly
which is the purpose of that is to make
sure you're keeping up forces you to go
over the lectures and it will just be
two or three questions per lecture what
I think are the salient points that you
should be getting away so it'll be at
course works 10% of your grade very easy
you can do it in 10 minutes
but it really just tells you what I'd
like you to take home and make sure you
keep up okay so with that the first one
will go up tonight on last week's one
lecture and it will be up on course
works until say Sunday night and then
Monday another one will go up okay and
if you don't if for some reason you
don't take the exam and you would like
to just email me because I will turn it
off after each week but if you want to
see it again just let me know okay so
that's that course works now today we're
going to talk about the infectious cycle
how it is that viruses infect cells and
we also call the infectious cycle virus
replication same thing synonymous terms
it is the sum total of everything that
happens from the point when a virus
attaches to its cell everything that
happens in between until new virions are
made and they're released from selves so
that's infectious cycle or virus
replication so during this process you
make many copies of the viral genome you
package them into particles and then
those particles come out of the cell and
reinfect these are all processes that we
will talk about in detail during this
course everything begins with one cell
whether it's in an animal or in cell
culture and today we're going to look at
the ways we study this infectious cycle
in a single cell and this is an example
of a typical infectious cycle for a
virus this happens to be polio via
but there's one for every virus they're
all different
and we as virologist like to divide the
infectious cycle into discrete stages to
help study and describe them but of
course in an infected cell there is no
first stage second stage third state
everything happens in a continuum but we
do that we make artificial boundaries
where they don't exist so here for
example is an infectious cycle of
poliovirus
it starts with the process called
attachment and entry the viruses bind to
receptors on the cell surface they enter
the cell in some way here we just show
the genome appearing in the cytoplasm
but there are specific mechanisms that
lead to that which we will talk about
and then what happens next depends on
the kind of nucleic acid that each virus
encases so in this case the virus has a
plus stranded RNA inside the capsid so
that means the first thing that can
happen is that it can be translated in a
cell nothing else is necessary except
the RNA here we show the translation
process the production of viral proteins
and eventually those proteins give rise
to new capsids new shells for the viral
genome but of course you also have to
replicate the nucleic acid and that's
shown here as well for this virus the
nucleic acid is replicated or copies are
made of it on membranous vesicles within
the cytoplasm and we'll talk about this
process in some detail and eventually
the virus RNA comes together with the
capsid proteins new virions are made and
released this infectious cycle for polio
happens to take place only in the
cytoplasm of the cell nucleus isn't
needed at all we could in fact take the
nucleus out of this cell and the virus
would replicate normally it's not the
case for many other viruses will see
many have nuclear requirements some more
than others so before we move on to
talking about infectious cycles and how
we study them some important definitions
I'll often talk about a susceptible cell
has a very precise definition that
simply means it is a cell with a
functional receptor
for a given virus whether or not the
cell can support viral replication has
does not is not encompassed in the term
susceptible all that refers to is
whether the cell has a receptor for the
virus or not so our resistance cell
doesn't have a receptor very simple
doesn't matter what could happen in the
cell if you could bypass say the
receptor requirement doesn't matter in
terms of susceptibility and resistance
all that refers to is receptor now these
are very specialized definitions
obviously because susceptible and
resistance in other walks of life have
very different meanings and finally the
permissive cell a permissive cell is one
that can replicate the virus in other
words if the virus could get inside of
that cell if it's if the virus can
replicate in that cell the cell is
permissive again it has no implications
about susceptibility that is the
presence or absence of a virus receptor
all right now as you might imagine the
cell that a virus can bind to and enter
and replicate in is both susceptible and
permissive so it has receptors on the
cell surface and it is permissive
meaning that once the virus gets past
the plasma membrane it has everything it
needs in order to replicate make more
genomes and make more particles alright
so we'll use these over and over in this
course so I think this is something that
is worth committing to memory now let's
start with the infectious cycle again
and how we study it animal viruses
remember from last time we're discovered
in the early 1900s but when they were
first discovered there were no cell
lines or no cell cultures that could be
used to propagate them we'll talk about
cell cultures in a moment the early
biologists aside from the bacterial
viral ageist the bacteriophage of
biologists they could use bacteria to
grow their viruses in but those who
studied animal viruses had to use
animals mice rabbits primates anything
that the
virus could replicate in and it wasn't
until many years later that we learned
how to grow viruses and cells so in fact
most viruses were not only studied in
animals but they were propagated in them
you would take for polio virus for
example you would take a monkey and
infect the monkey with virus the monkey
would get paralyzed with in sacrifice
it'd take out the spinal cord grind it
up and you would have a stock of virus
and then because there weren't freezers
at the turn of the 20th century
you couldn't store your virus stock so
you had to keep passing it in animals
every week but however long the
infection took so it was quite laborious
now one of the first aside from animals
one of the first substrates for growing
viruses was the embryo naded egg and
most commonly chicken eggs this is shown
here but other species have been used as
well and an embryo nated chicken egg of
course has an embryo in it as well as a
yolk sac and albumin to nourish it and a
variety of viruses can it be introduced
into this egg and they will grow in
various places now nowadays we don't use
this for anything really other than
growing influenza viruses and these
viruses are propagated by what's called
Alan TOEIC inoculation these embryo
native eggs have a variety of cavities
one of them is the Alan TOEIC cavity
which has a lot of fluid in it to
support the embryo you can drill a hole
in the shell and inject the virus into
that fluid directly and the virus will
propagate in the cells lining the cavity
and then after a suitable period of
enough of incubation you can then take
the fluid out and you have virus
instantly and you can also inoculate
other parts of the egg as shown here but
the point is that it's mainly used for
influenza virus now influenza vaccines
are largely propagated in embryo nated
chicken eggs
and this is just an example of a
facility where they use automated
machinery to inoculate the eggs to
incubate them and then to harvest the
fluid one egg makes basically a dose of
influen
is a vaccine and so we make 140 hundred
50 million doses a year here in the US
it's a lot of eggs so you can't have
someone standing there through the
syringe and occu lating them so it's all
automated now this is the reason why if
you're allergic to eggs or feathers you
shouldn't be injected with the influenza
vaccine now when we got the ability to
grow cells in culture we could then
study the infectious cycle in them and
you'll see why it was necessary to have
cells to do that that wasn't possible
before 1949 for animal viruses we could
do it for bacteria and they in fact led
the way and studying the infectious
cycle as you'll see
but 1949 was an important year for
animal viruses because that's when three
scientists at Harvard Medical School
learned that they could grow poliovirus
in a human cell culture and they took
human embryos and disrupted them and
made various cell cultures and they said
they found that that poliovirus would
grow in them and no one had been able to
do that before and they won the Nobel
Prize for that in 1954 the head of the
lab was actually John Enders and Weller
and Robbins were both medical students
working for him and when he got the call
that he was going to get the Nobel Prize
he said you have to include Weller and
Robbins and they did as well so that was
1954 and then John Enders made the cover
of Time magazine medicine gains on
viruses I think this is 1961 it's not
something we see anymore nowadays
although there was a virologist on the
cover of Time not too long ago within
the last decade anybody have any clue
who that might be
I'll give you a hint he's right here in
New York City David Howe retroviral
adjust HIV viral adjust in fact so last
virologist I remember who knows maybe
some of you will be viral adjust one day
and you'll will be on the cover of Time
so nowadays we have different kinds of
cell culture that we use to propagate
viruses on the left or primary cell
cultures that happens to be primary
human
for skin fibroblasts foreskins are very
easily available these days you can get
them and disassociate them and make very
nice cell cultures which are useful for
growing a number of viruses but a
primary cell culture is not immortal
it will only propagate for so many
divisions and then it will die so it has
limited usefulness unless you want to
keep getting four skins over and over
which you have to do for some viruses so
get over that problem you make an
immortal cell line and they can be
immortalized in a variety of ways by
chemicals or by viruses themselves but
now you have what's called the cell line
which you can propagate indefinitely so
here is an immortal Mouse cell line the
3t3 line here's a human epithelial cell
line the HeLa cell line so we call these
continuous cell lines and they've been
enormous ly useful for studying many
viruses but the problem is they're not
normal they have odd numbers of
chromosomes they have not the normal
number of human chromosomes that have
other aberrations as well and if you
want to grow vaccines you don't want to
use these for vaccine propagation so
other cell lines have been developed
which are called diploid cell strains
these have the normal numbers of human
chromosomes and they will multiply for a
fixed number of divisions they will
eventually die so they're not immortal
but they will live longer than the
primary cells so they're useful for
vaccine production so here we have an
illustration of how you can grow some of
these cell cultures these are cell lines
grown in an incubator in the laboratory
they're grown typically in plastic
dishes and flasks and they're covered
with medium the the cells adhere to the
plastic and propagating and you can use
these to grow your and study or viruses
and now some cells can be grown in what
we call suspension cultures so this is a
flask sitting on a spin on a magnetic
plate and it has cells in it and there's
a spin bar here suspended on a glass rod
and this turns around by virtue of the
magnet in the plate below it and so
these cells are growing in suspension as
a po
to being adhered to the plastic the
advantage of this is that you can grow a
lot of cells the volumes and numbers you
can grow are much greater than in those
cell culture plates and these in fact
are HeLa cells growing in my laboratory
and just to take a very brief aside here
HeLa cells were the first human cell
line to be made that was immortal and
Henrietta Lacks was was a woman in 1951
who had a tumor on her cervix that was
removed at Johns Hopkins and gave rise
to these HeLa cell lines and these cells
outlived her and it was only many years
later that her family actually learned
that these cells had been taken from her
and that whole story is the topic of
this book which was published last year
The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks and
Rebecca Skloot actually gave a seminar
in biology department here last year
it's very interesting story now how do
we detect the the fact that viruses are
growing in cells one of the ways we can
do it is by what's called cytopathic
effects and John Enders when he first
took cell cultures and infected them
with polio that's how he detected that
there was virus growing because the
cells died so cytopathic effect or CPE
it's alteration in the behavior and the
appearance of cells caused by virus
infection we'll talk about this a lot in
this course so here's an example of HeLa
cells on the upper left these are
uninfected HeLa cells they make a very
nice mono layer on the plastic dish you
infect them with polio and then four
hours later you can see the cells are
beginning to round up by eight hours
they've all detached and by 16 hours
they're all dead so this is what we call
cytopathic effect there are many
different kinds of cytopathic effects
not just this sort of rounding up here's
another kind of cytopathic effect this
one is called the formation of since
Isha in some cases some viruses when
they infect cells lead the cells to fuse
so adjacent cells fuse to one another
so two and four and eight cells will
fuse giving you a very big cell with
many nuclei this is called a syncytium
we'll get at the basis for this later
but it's another form of cytopathic
effect you can see it here in this cell
culture this is a cell culture infected
with a virus that causes fusion these
are the individual cells here and you
can see a syncytium a big cell with a
lot of nuclei okay another form of
cytopathic effect so here are examples
of different sorts of cytopathic effects
you don't need to learn all these I'm
showing these to you just to show you
that viruses do things in very different
ways to cells so for example there are
morphological alterations I just showed
you rounding up and detachment of cells
caused by polio other viruses do it as
well they can break up the chromosomes
they can cause syncytium formation as I
showed you vacuoles in the cytoplasm etc
and then their inclusion bodies also
these are bodies or assemblies in the
cell that are sometimes very specific
for the virus so for example
adenoviruses make virions in the nucleus
which you can see very clearly the negra
body refers to the assembly of very ons
in the cytoplasm which is very
characteristic of rabies so in fact if
someone is suspected to have rabies and
you can get a sample of infected cells
from that individual you will see negra
bodies in them if it's really a rabies
infection Guarnieri bodies again for
parks viruses and so forth so different
kinds of cytopathic effects during
infection of animal cells now i want to
talk about two general ways that we can
assay the infectivity of viruses besides
looking at the what they do to cells how
can we quantify the amount of virus that
is present and a first way will be the
measurement of infectious units so
viruses can be infectious we can measure
it and we also measure virus particles
in their component that's not an
infective 'ti measurement for many
viruses we can't do infective 'ti
measurements so we use alternative
so I want to talk about these now for
most of the time the first infectivity
essay is the plaque assay and this was
developed in the 1930s again by the
virologist who studied bacterial viruses
and what they found was if they took
their virus and mixed it with a
bacterial culture and then spread the
culture on an agar plate when they
incubated this plate
wherever the virus was multiplying there
was a hole in the bacterial mono layer
so this cloudy background if you will is
a layer of bacteria and then the virus
clears the layer for a little iris
anyway wherever there's been an
infection so you can count each of these
plaques and you assume that each one
arises from one virus and calculate the
titer of the virus as we'll see in a
moment so this was first done with
bacteria phages again because we didn't
have cell cultures for animal viruses
but once John Enders did his magic then
it was done for animal viruses that was
done in 1952 by renato dulbecco who
showed that animal viruses could form
plaques on animal cells just like
bacteriophages he got the Nobel Prize in
1975 partly for for this work as well as
other work as well
here's his paper the abstract of his
paper in 1952 production of plaques and
monolayer tissue cultures by single
particles of an animal virus and it's
interesting to read this first paragraph
research on the growth characteristics
and genetic properties of animal viruses
has stood greatly in need of improved
quantitative techniques such as those
used in the related field of
bacteriophage studies he's basically
saying we need quantitative techniques
to study animal viruses and we have to
do what the bacteriophage people have
done as well so he did that so what is a
plaque assay to do a plaque a say you
take a stock of virus and you make
serial dilutions typically you make ten
fold serial dilutions which means in
this case you can take 0.1 ml of your
virus and mix it with 0.9 ml of a
buffer that's a tenfold dilution and
then you do that down the line and then
you take a little bit of each dilution
and you infect separate plates of cells
so you have some kind of animal cell
growing on a monolayer you infect with
that allow the virus to adsorb and then
you cover the cells with a semi-solid
overlay all right
the semi-solid overlay restricts the
diffusion of the virus if you put a
liquid overlay on top what would happen
the virus would come out of the first
infected cells and would infect
everything and wipe all the cells out
you wouldn't be able to count anything
so you put a semi-solid overlay
typically auger or agarose carboxymethyl
cellulose some kind of medium to
restrict the diffusion of the virus
particles that produces localized
destruction visible as a plaque and then
you can count the plaques so here we
have 17 plaques on this plate the
dilution can be back calculated so that
we now know that we have one point seven
times ten to the eighth pfu per mil so
the original dilution was minus six plus
another tenfold dilution because we put
only 0.1 ml on and then that would be 17
times 10 to the seventh if you move the
decimal place over one one point seven
times ten to the eighth plaque forming
units per mil so that's how that's
calculated so let's look at a little bit
about how a plaque develops just to make
sure you understand this so when you
infect a plate of cells you don't put a
lot of viruses on that cell maybe a
hundred or so so that you can count the
plaques and each virus starts out by
infecting a single cell and because it's
under a semi-solid overlay when that
cell releases its new virus particles
they spread only to neighboring cells
and those in turn spread viruses to
neighboring cells so that the zone of
cell killing gets bigger and bigger and
then after a certain incubation period
you take off the overlay and stain the
cells and you can see holes in the mono
layer all right now here's another view
of plaques on the left is a photograph
high magnification of a viral plaque you
can see the intact cells on the outside
inside the cells have been killed so if
you take the overlay off these dead
cells wash off and you can stain them on
the right is a different view this is a
virus that has an enzyme a gene encoding
an enzyme inserted into its genome so
that you can stain the plaque with a
substrate that gives rise to blue color
and so you can see now on this mono
layer instead of staining with a dye
that would stain the cells you are now
staining the cells within the plaque
because that's where the virus is okay
now I have I have two movies of plaque
formation which just came out last year
these are formation of a plaque in pox
virus infected cells so what these
individuals did was they infected a
monolayer with virus and then after
about eight hours they put the plate on
a microscope stage the stage was
surrounded by an incubator and then they
found an infected cell and then they put
a movie camera on top and took a frame
every X number of minutes so what we're
going to see here is the development of
a plaque in real time starting from the
middle you can see the cell death is
spreading outwards so this is going to
repeat over and over again the initial
infected cell and then eventually all
the surrounding cells become infected as
well I think this is an hours up here so
it's 15 hours by the end of the
experiment so this is the first time I
could show this last year this
development of a plaque in real time and
this is basically what is happening to
give you that zone of of clearance now
in the next movie what we've done is
we've taken the same virus and we've
inserted a gene for green fluorescent
protein into the virus so now we can
visualize the viruses in the cells as a
green color so this is now the edge of
the plaque you can see it's moving out
as the cells are dying they're changing
and refraction so the plaque and then
the cells are making green fluorescent
protein so you notice actually that the
killing is proceeding the green it's
because the green is expressed late in
the viral replication cycle
all right so the cells are dying because
virus is in them and then later on the
cells make green protein because it's
the late proteins okay so that's how a
plaque develops and to show you the
staining procedure these are cells that
were infected with influenza virus in
the terms of a plaque assay and these
are three different dilutions and they
were stained after a couple of days and
you can see the clearing of the mono
layer where the virus has killed the
cells so it's very easy to count these
plaques and calculate the plaque titer
okay so now we ask the question how many
viruses do you need to form a plaque
just remember that when I when we
calculate the titer by this method we're
using platforming units per milliliter I
don't say infectious viruses per
milliliter because we're not not sure if
it's just one so that's an interesting
question
do you need one or do you need more well
how do you figure that out well you do
an experiment fold a dose-response curve
when you do a dose-response experiment
and you plot the data as a dose-response
curve and what you do is you'd make
dilutions of virus here we're putting
increasing amounts of virus and then you
do a plaque assay and count the number
of plaques so if one virus is enough to
make a plaque the dose-response curve
will be linear that is it follows one
hit kinetics the number of plaques is
directly proportional to the first power
of the concentration of the virus and
occu lated so if the concentration is
doubled the number of plaques doubled
single hit kinetics suggest that one
virus is sufficient to make a plaque so
this is real experimental data so it
shows in fact one is sufficient there
are some viruses however where you need
to vary ons to make a plaque for two and
that's called two-hit kinetics and the
curve of that experiment is the blue one
for to hit kinetics the number of
plaques is directly proportional to the
square of the concentration of virus and
occu later for some viruses the genomes
are packaged in separate caps it's half
of the genome is in one and half is in
the other then they both have to infect
the cell in order to
get an infectious cycle but for most of
the viruses we will talk about one is
sufficient to make a plaque now we often
use plaque purification to make clonal
stocks of viruses this is plaque
purification we do a plaque assay
instead of taking the mana layer off and
staining the mana layer which would kill
the cells and the virus we leave the
mana layer on and most times you can
actually see the plaques if you hold the
dish to the light and you can take a
pipette and plunge it into one of those
plaques and then you get the virus
that's within that piece of augur so you
take a little plug of agar you put it in
buffer and the virus comes into the
buffer and you can repeat this a few
times and then eventually we get what we
called clonal virus stocks now why do
you think we would have to do this
multiple times any idea I mean it looks
like there's one plaque here why would I
need to do it three times just to make
more work for the graduate students no
okay you have to do it because you don't
know if two viruses fell in the same
place it could happen and made one
plaque so that wouldn't be a clonal
virus stock because it would be arising
from do different viruses so we do
multiple plaque purifications just to
get around that likelihood now another
kind of assay for infectivity is the
endpoint dilution assay some viruses
just do not make plaques on any kind of
cell so you can't use the plaque acid to
titrate their infectivity so you use
this assay endpoint dilution what we're
doing here is measuring cell killing by
the virus and we're figuring out the
delusion that will give us half of the
cells infected or as measured by cell
killing so what you do is you make a
series of delusions of virus minus 2
minus 3 minus 4 and then you infect
wells of cells so this is a 96-well
plate and you infect the whole row with
one dilution and X dilution and so forth
and you incubate the cells and then
after so many days you stain them and
you you you record which monolayers are
in which or not you can easily tell that
when you stain them so here we've quant
we've put those data for one experiment
so at a minus two dilution all the cells
are killed
same thing with minus three now minus
four we see one well is not dead
so we've diluted out the virus such that
one well is protected and here at minus
five let's say we have one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten one
two three four five are killed and five
are not killed so we say the 50%
infectivity dose for this virus is ten
to the five so we say there are 10 to
the five 50% infectivity doses so that's
method of quantifying the virus that you
can use to standardize experiments so we
call it tissue culture infectious dose
is 50 percent now there is another very
interesting phenomenon in virology and
that is that if you do a plaque assay
and you calculate the pfu per mil of a
virus stock and then if you could
somehow count the number of particles
you could use an electron microscope or
some other ways turns out that not every
particle seems to be infectious in a
plaque assay so this is the number of
virus particles at a sample divided by
the number of infectious particles
measured say by a plaque asset so you
get it's called the particle to pfu
ratio this we don't do very often
because you we don't routinely look at
virus preparations in the microscope and
count them but this was done many years
ago and that's where this information
comes from for many bacteria phages this
number is 1 that means every phage
particle that you see in an electron
microscope is infectious it can give
rise to a plaque on a lawn of bacteria
but it's higher typically for most
animal viruses it's it can go from 1 to
10,000 and this makes life hard for
biologists because when you do an
experiment if only 1 in 10,000 of your
particles is infectious you're not quite
sure what you're looking at in your
ferma so here's an example of the
particle 2p a few ratios of a variety of
animal viruses from adenoviruses DNA
viruses herpes papillomas poly ouma's
poxviruses to some RNA viruses you can
see some of them are one or two which is
good but others are higher 20 100 200
and 10,000 so this is a complicating
factor for studying viruses but maybe
the more interesting question is why why
is this the case why do we find that not
every physical particle is infectious
well there are a couple of reasons first
of all you remember the dose response
curve that we showed a few slides ago
that tells us that a single particle is
enough to initiate infection one
particle is enough to make a plaque but
it doesn't tell us that all viruses are
successful at doing that all it tells us
is that one is is able to do it so why
not well some particles may be damaged
so when viruses propagate they can make
damaged particles or when you make
stocks in the laboratory maybe you
damaging the particles can have
mutations in the genome and we'll see
later that every virus stock has many
many mutations in it but I think
possibly the most important fact there
is that the infectious cycle is very
complicated there are multiple steps
that have to occur in order if you're
proceeding along the infectious cycle
and we'll talk about the individual
steps of each and in a lecture here in
this course if you fail at an early step
you never get to the end you can't
bypass the early step so if in just
terms of randomness if the virus fails
at an early step it never completes the
cycle so because they would say twelve
or fourteen steps in an infectious cycle
this may explain why not every particle
can complete it so that's the particle
to pee a few ratio now let's move into
how we can use this virus and cell
culture system to study replication in a
very important experiment that's used
over and over in virology it's called
the one step growth cycle and as you may
guess this was first worked out for
bacteria phages here's a
Furio virus infecting a bacterium this
was done in 1939 Ellis and delbruck who
used ecoli the bacterium and the phages
of that bacterium and what they did they
would add virus to their cells and let
it attach
that's called adsorption then they
diluted the culture and that prevents
further adsorption
so it basically synchronizes the
infection so all the phages that were
attached are the ones that are going to
go on to do the rest of the infection no
more infections will occur because the
culture has been diluted they then
incubate this culture at 37 degrees and
take a sample every few minutes and do a
plaque assay and ask how much infectious
bacteria phage is present and they
plotted those on graphs and this is what
they look like so on the left is an
example of this experiment where all the
cells in the culture were infected so
what you have is initially you have no
phages detected by plaque assay so here
we have time versus the number of
infectious particles determined by a
plaque assay so initially we don't see
any infectivity even though we added
bacteria phages we don't see it and then
suddenly there's a burst of infectious
virus production so that's called the
burst they saw this very rapid
production of phages they called it a
burst and that's stuck until today and
then eventually it plateaus we call this
a one-step growth curve because we have
one all the cells are infected and
there's one cycle of replication and
virus production so a single cycle of
replication produces this verse now if
you do a different experiment and don't
add a lot of virus in the beginning we
had fewer virus particles so that only a
few bacteria are infected then you get
multiple bursts so you have your initial
lag you have the first burst but not
every cell isn't is producing virus
those cells produce virus which then
goes on to infect the uninfected cells
in the culture and you have your second
burst here so these are two very typical
patterns of growth curves is the one
step this is obviously a multi cycle
growth curve and this led to the
description of very specific phase
of the growth cycle and one of them here
is the eclipse phase that's this phase
here where we don't see any infectivity
we just take these samples from this
culture and assay for PF fuse we don't
see anything they called it the Eclipse
phase and they figured out that this is
because what happens is early an
infection the genome comes out of the
virus and it's no longer infectious in a
plaque assay so the genome comes out you
can't detect it in a plaque assay and
you have to wait till new virions are
assembled to see infectivity and that's
what you see in the bursts so these in
the case of phages or in this experiment
in particular new infectious viruses can
be detected inside of the cell before
they are released into the medium so
this is actually what we see here they
didn't in their initial experiments they
didn't actually separate the cells from
the medium because in bacteria phages
and many bacteria phages that viruses
are assembled inside the cell and
they're actually infectious inside the
cell then they're released so in this
experiment they're measuring both but as
we'll see you can separate the two now
what do you think happened next well the
animal virologist took the one-step
growth curve and did their own version
once John Enders had showed them how to
grow viruses in cells so here's an
example of a growth curve for an animal
virus adenovirus happens to be type 5
doesn't really matter
we've infected cells and at different
times after infection here the hours
after absorption we assay for plaque
forming units per mil and we have two
different assays here we have
intracellular virus and extracellular
virus so intracellular we take the cells
and centrifuge them out of the medium
break them open and measure the virus in
them and for extracellular we just take
the medium and remove any cells that
might be present so we can separate the
two and measure what's in the cell and
what's out of the cell so initially you
see this Eclipse period up to 12 hours
just as we did for bacteria phages we
can't detect any infectivity either in
the supernatant or in the cells
themselves then at about 12 hours just
after 12 hours you see we start to have
produced within the cell but we still
don't see anything extracellular Lee
until 16 hours actually past 16 hours so
there's a period here where we see
inside the cell infectious viruses but
not outside the cell so they've been
made and assembled but they just haven't
gotten out of the cell yet and that's
called the latent period from the
beginning of infection to the time when
they're put out of the cell so the
eclipsed period is the time when we
can't detect any infectivity whatsoever
wherever you look latent period is
simply the time you don't see infectious
virus outside of the cell eventually the
virus's virus production plateaus the
cells die and then the extracellular
viruses lag behind you can see the titer
is always lower because not everything
is not every particle will get out of
the cell now I just want to remind you
what's happening here is that a virus
has infected the cell and it's
programming the synthesis of new virus
particles all the parts are made the
genome is made the capsids structural
proteins they're assembled and new
viruses come out and that's illustrated
in this diagram we go from one virus to
many and this is in contrast to what
bacteria do and I'm pointing this out
because when the phage biologists first
began studying this they assumed that
phages would multiply like bacteria you
put a bacterium in a culture it divides
to make two bacterias immediately starts
to divide no lag period no Eclipse
period it goes to two and then four and
then eight 16 etc that's not what they
saw for viruses they saw a lag or an
eclipse period which means that the
components had to be made before new
viruses could be assembled very
fundamental difference the bacteria
which divided by division which multiply
by division can immediately begin doing
that without a lag because they don't
make parts they just divide their cells
now when we do these one-step growth
experiments it's important to
synchronize the infection so that
everything happens at the same time in
every cell in a culture that way you can
study it biochemically if in every cells
something different was happening
totally different
very difficult to trace what was going
on now you remember with the
bacteriophage one-step growth cycles the
way to synchronize was to dilute the
culture so no more viruses could attach
we do this with animal viruses in in two
ways we infect cells with enough virus
to infect all the cells at once so that
everything starts at the same time and
then we dilute the culture to prevent
absorption so the question is how do you
know when you have enough virus so can
you just throw a ton of virus on cells
or is there a precise way to measure
this well of course there is a precise
way and it has to do with what we call
the multiplicity of infection or mo I
usually like the lights on multiplicity
of infection this is how we determine
how many viruses we put on cells it is
the number of infectious particles added
per cell so if I have a million cells in
a plate and I add a million viruses what
is the multiplicity of infection one
it's real simple nothing tricky if
there's if there's ten million viruses
it's a multiplicity of ten that's what
I'm adding it doesn't mean that every
cell gets one virus though that's just
what I'm adding the multiplicity of
infection simply tells you how many
viruses you add per cell it's really
simple but what gets complicated is
figuring out how many particles each
cell receives that's the harder part
which will bring you through now but the
first part is very easy can look at it
this way if there are a hundred buckets
in this room and I could somehow carry a
hundred tennis balls and throw them well
at once each bucket wouldn't get one
ball right even though it's a hundred to
a hundred there would be some kind of
probability that would determine how
many balls got into each bucket how many
got zero balls one and more than one
it's exactly the same with viruses you
throw viruses on a plate of cells
there's some kind of probability
distribution which to term
how many viruses hit each cell and
that's determined by a very specific
probability equation called the Poisson
distribution and this is what I just
told you if you add 10 to the 7
variances of a million cells for an mo
eye of ten each cell doesn't receive ten
variants the number is different so the
Poisson distribution results in the fact
that some cells get no virus is no
matter how much virus you add some get
one two and three or more particles and
that's the Poisson distribution which is
this wonderful formula here at the top
which was figured out by plus some many
years ago and for viruses we've actually
rewritten it so that it means PK is the
fraction of cells that are infected by a
virus particles and M is the
multiplicity of infection so we can
actually simplify this equation
substantially and we can do that by
inserting for K either 0 1 or greater
than 1 and these are the equations that
result when you do that for example if
you put 0 into this equation this is how
it simplifies so p0 equals e to the
minus M the natural logarithm to the
exponent of the multiplicity of
infection so it's a very easy
calculation cells receiving one particle
p1 equals m e to the minus m and then
for greater than one here's the formula
which is basically subtracting from one
the sum of all probabilities for any
value of K so let's look at the numbers
you'd get with this formula if you
infect a million cells at an my of 10:45
cells then you plug that into the
formula if 45 cells are uninfected so
that's nothing in the culture of a
million cells 450 cells received just
one particle and the rest get more than
one so basically in a million cell at an
mo of 10 you've got everybody infected
so that's why we use mo i of 10 most of
the time in the laboratory but sometimes
we don't want to infect all the cells we
want to have a multi cycle infection to
study so we use a lower mo I let's try
one here 37 percent of the cells are
uninfected 30
seven received one particle and 26% more
than one so about seventy-five percent
of the cells end up getting infected
73% if we use 0.001 very low mo I 99
percent of the cells are uninfected so
0.1% or a thousand cells get one
particle and in a vanishingly small
percentage get more than one so most
most of the culture is on in fact that
you got a thousand cells infected that
would be too many to do a plac asset you
could never count a thousand Plex but
you could do a multi nice multi cycle
experiment at that MRI all right so
that's the poisson distribution how it
determines the number of particles
received by each cell so the simple part
is mo I just describes how many virions
you add per cell but the amount that
they actually get is the Poisson
distribution now that is all great when
you can measure infective 'ti but we
can't do that for a lot of virus
particles so we have to turn to other
means and we'll go quickly through these
hemagglutination electron microscopy
measuring enzymes serology and nucleic
acid based message methods many viruses
can hemagglutinin what this means is
that here's here's influenza virus its
receptor the moiety on a cell that it
binds to to start an infection happens
to be a sugar called sialic acid red
blood cells which are big have silac
acids on their surface it's very easy to
get red blood cells come by them and so
in 1941 George Hearst right here in New
York City figured out the assay for
measuring influenza virus using red
blood cells if you mix the virus with
red blood cells it will make them all
stick together because one virus will
stick to multiple red blood cells via
this sciatic acid and because red blood
cells are pretty big you can see this so
here for example is a hemagglutination a
say you make dilutions of your virus and
you mix them with red blood cells and
then you see which ones the red blood
cells stick to one another how can you
tell that well if the red blood
don't stick to one another they rolls to
the bottom of the well and they make a
nice little button so that means there's
no virus in this sample at all or this
one below but if there is virus present
the red blood cells make a nice mat
along the well and you can see that in
many of these wells here and so what you
basically do is you go to the dilution
where you don't see that mat anymore and
that's the H a titer of the virus so it
doesn't tell you about infectious
particles but it does tell you how much
virus is present which is useful for
many viruses we can't do plaque assay we
can't to H a team agglutination so we
measure viral enzyme activity as you
will see some animal viruses have
enzymes in the particle they have
nucleic acid polymer aces they have
other enzymes as well and you can
measure those so you mix virus particles
with some kind of nucleic acid precursor
you have two permeable eyes the particle
because these triphosphates can't get
through membranes so you mix them with a
little detergent the labeled
triphosphates get in the enzyme
polymerizes them and you can measure
that and this is most often done for
retroviruses which many of which do not
transform cells or form plaques so
here's an example of such an experiment
these are what individual wells of cells
and they've been infected three
different kinds of cells here at L n cap
D you 145 and wimpy one and they have
been infected either not infected MOC
infected or infected with a retrovirus
called XMRV either undiluted or one to
ten and then after a certain period of
time the supernatant of the culture is
taken supposedly has virus particles in
it you add a little detergent you add
the nucleoside triphosphate precursor
which is labeled with an isotope and
then you filter that through a membrane
and if there's any nucleic acid
synthesized in the particle it will
stick to the filter and you can detect
it so you see there's nothing in the
mock infected cells which you would
expect there's no virus there but the
virus infected cells
produce material when you add the
labeled precursor to the virion you can
see the virus apparently replicates in
this cell and in the wimpy ones but not
in the du1 45 so again it's a particle
measure we don't know anything about
infectivity we also use serological
methods to assay viruses if we have
antibodies to viral proteins we can use
those to stain infected cells we can do
either direct or indirect methods we
have an antibody to the virus here for
example which is labeled with a green
fluorescent color or we can use a second
antibody to detect the antibody binding
to the viral protein so these is this an
example of cells infected with a herpes
virus and they're stained with an
antibody to one of the viral proteins
which is in this and the indicator color
is green so this viral protein is in the
nucleus and the cells are also stained
with an antibody to tubulin to mark the
cytoskeleton western blotting is another
very often used technique to detect
viral infections and this procedure you
fractionate viral proteins on a
polyacrylamide gel these can be clinical
specimens from patients they can be cell
lysate from the laboratory you
fractionate them on the gel you transfer
the proteins to a membrane sheet
nitrocellulose or some other synthetic
sheet and then you add antibodies to
that sheet the antibodies will stick to
wherever the protein is and then
eventually you can detect the antibodies
by various means so knowing that these
extracts had so many proteins you can
now find out which of those are in fact
viral proteins if you're using viral
antibodies here and we'll look at a
method later on that relies on this for
diagnosis the lysa enzyme linked
immunosorbent assay is often used to
detect either viral proteins or
antibodies to viruses so if you want to
know if someone's infected with a virus
you can look for the viral proteins in
the blood or in some other tissue or you
can look for antibodies because we make
immune responses to viruses so here on
the left you you are carrying out what
we
call a sandwich Eliza you take a plastic
dish you add an antibody to it the
antibody will stick to the plastic you
then add your extract which you think
has viral proteins in it if that has
viral proteins they will stick to the
antibody and then finally you come in
with a second antibody to the viral
protein which now has a green or an
enzyme indicator linked to it so you can
say this sample has or has not viral
antigen in it in the same way you can
look for viral antibodies you couple
instead of coupling antibody to the
plastic you couple viral proteins and
then say you've taken serum from
patients who you suspect to be infected
you put the serum on top of this plastic
dish if there are antibodies to the
virus they will bind to the antigen and
then you can detect those by a second
antibody Gleek green fluorescent protein
and all of its variants have been very
useful in studying virus infective 'ti
the original one from the jellyfish of
course now varible and many other colors
the advantage is that this is visible in
living cells without fixing so you can
track virus infections in real time and
this is absolutely amazing the things
that you can do and many viral proteins
it turns can be fused to green
fluorescent protein or its derivatives
and still retain functions so we can
track the entire infectious cycle the
topic of what we've been talking about
here contract the whole cycle now in our
in a living cell by just looking at
these colors without having to kill the
cells to do that so let me show you some
examples of that on the left is a herpes
virus where the gene for green
fluorescent protein was inserted into
the genome you can now infect cells with
this virus and trace it the virus
movement by the color so this is a
neuron that's been infected with this
herpes virus and you can see the virus
is present and not only the cell body
but all the axons and dendrites by
virtue of seeing the green color and
this is used for example to trace
neuronal connections in an animal you
can inject them with such viruses and
then at different times image the animal
and see where the
virus is going on the right is an
experiment where HIV one was labeled
with green fluorescent protein and this
is the interior of a cell and you can
see these green dots are individual
viral proteins and the red is actually
an antibody the sorry the the cell is
the cell's tubulin protein is labeled
with a red fluorescent protein and you
can see that these very ons attached to
these cytoskeletal cytoskeletal elements
and move along them to get near the
interior of the cell so you can again
trace different parts of the infectious
cycle by doing this here's a movie of a
neuron of an animal sorry this is a
neuron in culture which was infected
with a herpes virus that produces green
fluorescent protein you can see
individual viral particles moving away
from the cell body they're produced in
the cell body and they move away let's
look at that again if I can click this
wrong way okay so the prions are
produced in the nucleus and then they're
moving out in the periphery so these are
individual virus particles visualized by
the presence of the green protein
southern blood hybridization is an old
technique but it's still used in in many
ways we can fractionate nucleic acids on
a gel and just like the Western blot
transfer them to membranes and hybridize
with radioactive probes so we can say of
all these fragments on this gel these
are the ones that contain a particular
viral sequence that we are interested in
and finally perhaps the most used and
maybe even abuse technique polymerase
chain reaction for detecting viral
infections this of course is an enormous
ly useful technique for research but
it's also used for diagnosis of
infections the basis you start with a
nucleic acid here it's a double-stranded
DNA but if you have an RNA virus that
you'd like to detect in the same way you
can make its RNA into DNA and it depends
on denaturing the DNA
and using primers to anneal to the
strands and amplify complementary
strands using heat-stable polymerases
the advantages of course that you can
use very specific primers so you can
look for whatever virus you're searching
for or you can make the generated
primers that look for a lot of different
viruses and you can start with a very
small amount of material and get enough
to see a signal so this is often used
for viral diagnosis and discovery as
we'll see so here is an example of the
use of PCR to study a population of
patients with the disease known as
chronic fatigue syndrome CFS a couple of
years ago was suggested that the virus
might be involved in this disease and so
this is an experiment where serum
actually these are peripheral blood
mononuclear cells lymphocytes and
macrophages from either patients with
CFS or normal controls the DNA from
these cells was purified and then
subjected to PCR with primers specific
for a retrovirus called xmrv so you can
see that in a good number of these
patients PBMCs they amplify a specific
DNA product which is the xmrv sequence
and you can see the normal controls are
largely devoid of this it's with the
exception of one so this is an example
of how you can use PCR to look for
something that perhaps doesn't grow well
in culture or which you don't suspect to
be present in the long run now the real
question is to prove that these viruses
do cause disease and that's much harder
than this PCR experiment now another
extremely often used technique is was
originally called pyro sequencing now it
should be really cool deep sequencing
it's when you can sequence many many
many molecules of nucleic acid at a very
deep level you can go down to almost
single molecules so it was originally
developed as pyro sequencing because the
method involved taking DNA that you want
a sequence denaturing it so you have
single strands and then attaching them
to beads very small beads such that each
bead gets one piece of DNA only
and then you amplify the sequences on
the beads and then you put the beads in
the well of a 96 or 1500 well plate will
you do sequencing reactions and these
are amazingly clever reactions they're
called pyro sequencing because they
depend on the release of pyrophosphate
in a reaction which we won't go into but
as each you add a polymerase to these
beads and the polymerase copies the
single-stranded nucleic acid that's
present and added as it adds a base that
base emits light which can be detected
by a machine so you can see the sequence
of the product basically by reading
about the colors of light that emerge so
this has now been used to sequence our
genome to take air from New York City
and sequence it and see what's present
and you can get millions and millions of
bases in fact there's a variant of this
now which will probably allow us to
sequence a human genome in a day or less
so it's incredibly powerful now it's
applied to viruses you can you can do a
lot of bases it's applied to viruses in
a variety of ways it's applied to virus
discovery and this is an example of the
kinds of problems that arise so this is
a paper where they looked in children
with respiratory disease and just took
sputum samples and in this case they did
PCR but another work they have also done
sequencing and they discover new viruses
as a consequence so Rhino viruses are
the most prevalent human pathogens there
they cause half of all common colds and
there are about a hundred serotypes so
since the 1950s we've we've discovered a
hundred different rhinoviruses because
we can grow them in culture but after
about 1970 we didn't discover anymore
but when these individuals took sputum
and clinical specimens from the upper
tract of kids and sequenced them or did
PCR they found rhinoviruses by the
dozens
of new rhinoviruses should never
discovered before because we couldn't
grow them in culture we have their
sequences we know they're different from
existing rhinoviruses so PCR and pyro
sequencing deep sequencing new methods
of discovering brand-new viruses but
then you have to prove that these
sequences cause disease so we just
finish up here with a discussion of this
so this takes us back to the German
bacteriologist Koch who you remember
from last time was seriously involved in
formulating the germ theory of disease
he said there are these microorganisms
and they cause disease and he formulated
what we call his postulates to prove
that any bacterium or any infectious
agent causes a disease so Koch said
first of all you have to regularly
associate the organism with a disease so
if you're looking at tuberculosis you
have to see in people with tuberculosis
you have to always see the organism in
those individuals secondly you have to
get the organism from the individual and
grow it in culture all right third you
have to put the organism back into a
healthy host and show that it course is
the same disease and finally you have to
get the isolate the organism from that
experimentally infected host so we said
you fulfill these four things and you
can prove that something is causing an
infectious disease so this is 1885 or so
so now we have we don't have organisms
anymore we have sequences right we don't
grow things because many of these
viruses can't be grown so what do we do
well and many viruses actually end up
being discovered to cause the disease
before you can grow them in culture so
you can't even fulfill one of Cox boss
with hepatitis C virus for example was
discovered as the agent of hepatitis and
couldn't be grown up until recently
Kaposi sarcoma virus same thing human
papillomaviruses causative agents of
cervical cancer couldn't be grown for
many years so we really need Koch's
postulates to address these problems the
discovery of pathogens by sequencing
the inability to grow them in culture so
here are some proposed Koch's postulates
for the 21st century instead of saying
like coke did that you can isolate the
the organism should be present in all
cases with the disease what we say is
the nucleic acid sequence should be
present in most cases of an infectious
disease not all we've now regressed a
little to most because we can never get
it in most and the at nucleic acid
should be in the organs that have
disease so if it's a lung disease you
should get the nucleic acid sequences in
a lung sample and then in hosts without
disease you should get fewer or no
nucleic acids okay it doesn't have to be
0 recognizing that there may be some
pathogens that are in everyone but they
don't cause disease maybe they only
cause disease in certain individuals
number 3 when the disease goes away the
nucleic acid copy number goes down it
decreases or maybe goes away entirely if
you get sick again you should see the
nucleic acids again so you see we're
just making an exception by substituting
nucleic acid for organism now when the
seat when you find the sequence before
you find disease or when the copy number
cause it correlates with severity of the
disease then causation is more likely to
be correct the Association is more
likely to be a causal relationship the
nature of the microorganism that you
deduce from the sequence should be
consistent with the characteristics of
all other related organisms that's
common sense
and finally tissue sequence correlates
should be sought in other words efforts
should be made to demonstrate in a
tissue section in areas that are
diseased that there are sequences
present and that sequences are not
present in neighboring areas that are
healthy so these are ways to and these
things should be reproducible so not
just once you have to do it over and
over again these are actually just
suggestions and they have been made in a
variety of publications but they under
SCOR the problem that we have is that we
have incredible technology that lets us
discover things discover new pathogens
but associating with diseases is hard
because we don't grow them anymore now
the last two slides I want you to
remember that what we've talked about
today is infecting cells in culture with
a virus we've talked about growth cycles
and multiplicity of infection but in a
tissue culture dish in the laboratory
this is totally unreal right because you
or any animal that gets infected is a
mixture of different cell types and all
sorts of different environments so you
have to understand that a cell culture
experiment in the lab is an idealized
representation and in oversimplification
in the real world the virus particle has
to encounter a host well here we take
our dish of cells and we put the virus
on it but you have the virus has to find
you and that's not very easy because
viruses have no means of locomotion they
can't move they're subject to whatever
moves and Brownian motion air currents
water and so forth they have no
locomotion they move by diffusion
limited processes the environment is
very tough on small particles UV
radiation drying dilution low pH mucus
all sorts of things work against viruses
being successful very different from a
cell culture dish where you put a virus
on and every cell gets infected and then
once the virus does encounter a host
it's got to evade host defenses we'll
talk a lot about immune defenses later
on they're a significant obstacle of
course they don't exist in cell culture
cell culture has no immune defenses only
in organisms so we have skin which is
often the outer layer of our skin is
dead and no virus can infect that our
layer so you have this huge obstacle to
infection unless there's a cut or
something very hard for the virus to get
in we do have mucosal surfaces our eyes
respiratory and alimentary urogenital
tracts those are very susceptible to
infection but they do have mucous and
they have matrices that block infection
so there are a lot of barriers but some
viruses do get in the host and there
there are other defenses as well
there are innate and adaptive defenses
so the point here is that it's not easy
to infect an animal and I've told you
today how easy it is to infect the plate
of cells and do a one step growth
culture but it's not really easy in
animals and the last image I want to
leave you with is that in animals viral
infections usually begin that exposed
epithelial surfaces your your skin is
dead but you can get through the outer
layer of skin and the mucosal membranes
are all susceptible we have different
kinds of surfaces we have different
kinds of cells in different
configurations and we also have apical
basal and lateral surfaces as well so
this is all very different from what
happens in a plate of cells where you
add virus to the tops of the cells it
affects in a uniform environment so I
just want you to keep that in mind one
step growth cycles are great for
studying certain aspects of replication
but in the real world it's a lot harder
for viruses to be successful
you